woher kommen wir
wer sind wir wohin machine bier um diese
großen fragen drehen sich vier
historische filme die diesen monat auf
den sendern der srg zu sehen sein werden
die reihe unter dem titel die schweizer
beleuchtet herausragende
persönlichkeiten der schweizer
geschichte
uri schwyz und unterwalden könnte das
ganze team 2005
sie waren groß
und vergessen der crash mädels alles gut
einer der stars daniel i er spielt den
legendären heerführer und bürgermeister
von zürich hans waldmann
doch die helden dieses reporters sind
die die neben rampenlicht stehen obwohl
kein film ohne sie auskommen würde die
statisten silke birnbaum 27 jahre alt
und stefan hable ziel 29 jährige
es regnet schwarz zeitungslesen mit dem
weltweiten trend begann
rapperswil am zürichsee morgens um halb
acht
silke birnbaum und stefan hartl hatten
gute gründe sich zu melden als eine
agentur mittelalter statisten für die
großproduktion die schweizer suchte doch
dazu später
der elektromaschinenbauer aus effretikon
steht zum ersten mal vor einer
filmkamera
[Musik]
ja
als erstes übt sich der neuling in der
wichtigsten tugend eines statisten
geduld
stephan oetzel ist viel zu sauber für
das mittelalter die maskenbildnerin
macht aus dem gepflegten jungen mann
einen verdreckten städter des 15ten
jahrhunderts die zügig wird man braucht
man als held empfangen
der ansatz später dann in roda zu weit
aus dem fenster lehnen von augen und
trieb seine vier stücken die schöne
augen machen und die kunsthalle zu
werfen
stefan hablützel und zecke birnbaum sind
seit drei jahren ein paar
was im fertigen film als altstadt von
zürich ausgegeben wird ist in der
realität eine gasse im sanktgallischen
rapperswil der regisseur gibt letzte
anweisungen dass die sprache englisch
ist wenn ein welscher mit
deutschschweizern arbeitet gehört auch
zur schweizer identität während im
hintergrund die proben laufen verpasst
die maskenbildnerin stefan hablützel
mittelalterlich ungepflegte zähne im
richtigen leben vermarktet silke
birnbaum elektronikgeräte
ich weiß dass ich irgendwann habe jetzt
zwei jubler villa schlacht gehabt und
dass ich einfach dastehen und sagen
wichtig ist wer eine zu bauen oder führe
laufend zu mir wichtig wie der kamera
natürlich das land voran darunter eben
auch nur einfach das projekt und dem
kundenteam nicht haben oder über alte
und werden dann lege ich hab dann auch
rasch das publikum richter und handys
und uhren noch schnell verstecken und
alle machen sich bereit für die erste
aufnahme
[Applaus]
[Musik]
damit die kamera ohne wackler neben hans
waldmann mitfahren kann hat das filmteam
schienen verlegt
[Applaus]
in der fertigen szene sieht man silke
birnbaum für wenige sekunden
[Musik]
und stephan hat löten ist am linken
bildrand angeschnitten
er lügt niemand wird die beiden im film
beachten
und doch ohne sie wäre der held völlig
verloren erst statisten bringt leben in
einem film
im emmental
hier sind keine teuren kameras der
filmproduktion im einsatz
dies sind die vorbereitungen zum
traditionellen mittelaltermarkt eine der
hauptattraktionen ist die
mittelaltergruppe der rote hufen der
verein von silke birnbaum und stefan
hablützel spielt so authentisch wie
möglich eine reisegruppe im jahr 1210
der strom am computer sondern erstmal
erwartet sie zurück versetzt der verein
hat 25 mitglieder
sie alle sind getrieben von einer großen
begeisterung für das mittelalter
stephan appel hat in den letzten wochen
ein mittelalterliches bett gebaut
alles soll so authentisch wie möglich
sein keine schrauben keine nägel
das paar hat sich im verein
kennengelernt
sendker birnbaum war bereits mitglied
als ihr stefan dazu stieß als liebesnest
dient ein strohsack
aber haben wir haben eigentlich kann man
das rentier zu einer stunde direkt auf
dasselbe zwei nachtclubs sie sicher auch
seiten auch info
so richtig und alles für mich getan also
es ist noch ein kleines bedürftigen
republik machen
ja aber ich denke dass ich ein rotes
liegt viel werden und jessica vorstellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der mittelaltermarkt den mut wie hat
seine pforten geöffnet
[Musik]
die musikgruppe des roten rufen spielt
zum tanz auf
[Musik]
hier treffen sich gleichgesinnte und
schwelgen im romantischen mittelalter in
diesem mittelalter gibt es keine pest
niemand muss hungern
[Musik]
dieses mittelalter ist ein bunter
spielplatz am rand des industrie
quartiers
[Musik]
stefan hablützel heißt in seiner rolle
als hauptmann der bewaffneten truppen
stefan von wild also hat das perlt
einfach dass ich ja liter auto muss man
auch mehr machen das ja nicht für
zuschauer allenfalls über usb nationen
wir machen das für uns immer gern machen
er blüht auf in dieser fantasiewelt und
hat sich für viel geld ein authentisches
ritter gewand zugelegt alleine das
kettenhemd wiegt 13 kilo
muss
[Musik]
ja
was passiert jetzt eben der
elektromaschinenbauer findet es ganz
normal in seiner freizeit so
herumzulaufen
er lebt in dieser welt letzte
anweisungen für den bevorstehenden show
kann
[Musik]
das funktioniert also dass die ganze
biografie von vorgang ich studiert hat
das dass das einfach auf gott also dass
jeder gedanke das muss man auch ein
plötzliches vergessen
[Musik]
sie kopieren baum hat mit ihrem freund
einen rabiaten streit einstudiert
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zurück auf dem filmset im ehemaligen
kloster rheinau hat die filmcrew ein
mittelalterliches bad nachgebaut
das junge paar steht wieder im einsatz
was die beiden sonst in ihrer freizeit
spielen wird hier professionell und mit
großem budget inszeniert der erzherzog
findet in der causa frisch an styling
habt ihr unklugen gilt und so sieht die
szene im fertigen film aus ich tun würde
was steckt für die blutigste voraus
fuhren wir zurück
er bestimmt haben sie den auftritt von
silke birnbaum verpasst im hintergrund
huscht sie durchs bild zu ihrem freund
stefan er ist hinter dem vorhang
verdeckt und im fertigen film nicht
einmal zu sehen dafür sind stoffe und
requisiten zu sehen die der mittelalter
fachfrau entschlüsseln entlocken
warum wohl aber am boulevard müller nein
das ist sogar und zucker sind auch jetzt
redet ihn hätten wir eigentlich noch mal
was versprechen zum bornheimer größter
verwendet
zurück in richtigen mittelalter zurück
in der fantasie von silke birnbaum und
stefan hablützel am mittelaltermarkt in
not wie leben sie ein wochenende lang in
ihren rollen salvia die badenerin
verwöhnt stefan von welchen den
hauptmann es richtig macht es fürs
trinken
stephan oetzel trat vor einigen monaten
einen modernen ritterorden bei er heißt
souveräner orten der ritter des weißen
falten und engagiert sich karitativ sich
voll und ganz verschrieben hat das ist
absolut uneigennützig nicht sich selber
die energie für schwächere beschützt
diego wehrlos sind und das ohne dass er
im garten hat sondern auch dass es über
zügig und dies auch
[Musik]
doch an diesem wochenende regiert die
lust am verkleiden und die freude am
rollenspiel immer wieder zetteln die
vereinsmitglieder spontan spielszenen an
eine vermeintliche die band wird dem
hauptmann vorgeführt
[Musik]
also war der beste auf der welt sicher
auflaufen ich habe vorhin zwei
hinzubekommen und wo die anderen meist
wirklich dass das ist natürlich dass ich
das sind haltlose jungenschule die
unmittelbarste habe ich bin so frei
klose
die meisten der beschuldigt dvi d ich
hoffe es eigentlich ist das alles ja das
hat der für die mitglieder des roten
hufen ist das mittelalter eine große
spielwiese die macher der historischen
filme der srg setzen das zeitalter als
reizvolle kulisse für den mythos der
schweiz in szene
[Musik]
vor der filmkamera waren stefan
hablützel und zelte birnbaum statisten
im hintergrund hier sind sie die stars
die helden in ihrem eigenen film
[Musik]
[Applaus]